an addiction to distraction is the death
of your creative production and we all
know about the dopamine addiction that
happens when you play with your phone
and so every time we look for like every
time we play with a phone every time we
respond to a notification there's a shot
of dopamine that creates a habit and
then over time the Habit turns into an
addiction that is just as powerful as an
addiction to cocaine there's a concept
known as attention residue and every
single time you respond to a
notification every single time you look
at your phone you deliver or give a
piece of your Priceless attention to
that notification and if you do it a
hundred times a day then by the end of
the day you have zero Focus I was in a
high quality Hotel relatively recently
and I ordered a large bottle of Evian
water and I kid you not they delivered
11 bottles of Evian water you want to
talk about the mistakes being made it is
stunning there are very few people who
are fully present and yet one of the
traits of the great Geniuses is is this
they could spend law long stretches of
time in acute Focus thinking about one
project free of distraction and then in
the book I talked about the model it's
called transient hypofrontality which is
really Flow State we all can tap into
Flow State where genius lives but you
don't get to do there if you're checking
your phone all day long hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I struggled
to stay afloat I quit my business
partner and the thing that kept me going
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how to get more
things done and overcome your
procrastination enjoy
rule number two is develop the done by
one mentality with Brendan burchard this
is something that I've practiced for
about the last
four years and it's been very very
helpful for me here it is
daily goals done by one what I want you
to do is every morning fill out your
high performance planner know what you
need to focus on and get done that day
and then ask yourself if I could only if
I had to get this done by one one pm
how would I do it
if I only got to work until 1 pm and I
know some of you only do work to 1 pm
because we had a lot of extraordinary
successful people in this community who
you know you work your mornings you take
your afternoons off I get it I
appreciate you too
but for those of you who have not
achieved that yet okay let's think about
it let's ask this question if you only
had let's imagine the day only went to
1pm
obviously you couldn't get everything in
so what do you have to focus on if
you're going to have done by one what do
you have to focus on
the major priorities and the needle
moving activities
write it down
the major priorities of the day
and the major needle moving activities
done by one
that's what I do then be like how does
he get so much done I'm probably not
doing any more than anybody else it's it
every day though the major priorities
and the major needle moving activities
done by one
write it down major priorities major
needle moving activities done by one
then guess what it leaves a whole
afternoon to all the randomness of life
right oh I got to take a call Great
guess what I don't take any calls until
the afternoon why I set that up so that
I can make sure that I focused on
the morning being dedicated towards
moving my life and my business forward
that was my progress check that's what I
focus on it's like did I do what is
necessary this morning before I took
random calls from other people asking me
things pitching me things interviewing
me on things
now some of you say that's just not
possible Brandon I gotta get the kids up
get them School come back
check my email respond to everybody else
and I'm like no
you need to do your job and get it done
by one the major needle moving
activities that are your job get it done
by one
you got to reorient the day now people
say well Brandon what is one I said well
one is kind of arbitrary isn't it
because if you got it done by two would
that be equally good yes but the done by
one because it Rhymes it sticks in your
brain a little bit right you guys like
this it's like done by one mentality
allows me
to move ahead faster because I imagine
go I only have till one o'clock to get
my major needle moving activities so
every day by one the major things that
had to get done that I had to do
I've either got them done or
significantly along the way
and that's what's important but many
people aren't doing that you know what
you're doing you're spending so much
time reacting to everybody else in the
morning that you're not doing the major
things that were on your plate that you
were supposed to do and that is why I
know without a questionable in my mind
that to double the progress of this
group we can do it guys we really can do
this we can double your progress if we
can help you adopt this mindset of done
by one
figure out what are the major priorities
of this day
and where the major needle moving
activities now I always get asked what's
the difference between the two Brennan
what's the difference between a priority
and like a needle moving activity of my
life or my business okay let's talk
about priorities maybe your priority
today let's say let's see one of your
priorities might be something as simple
as you know what
call my uncle
he's sick
he's sick in the hospital he's a
priority day I gotta call him okay I'm
gonna call him by one that's a priority
right a needle moving activity is an
activity usually related more towards an
output like an activity like okay uh
something moves the needle forward in
your brand or your business for me as an
example a podcast episode as simple as
that sounds might be a needle moving
activity great that moves the needle and
growing our our brand cool episode Done
by one oh needle moving activity that
may mean a major email broadcast to my
email list great
done by one
major needle moving activity
call somebody who uh you know I'm gonna
do a business deal with or who's gonna
be affiliate promotional partner
call is done by one because that was a
needle moving activity right something
that moves the business or your life
forward sometimes your priorities hey
your priorities can be relationships
your priorities can be handling things
for your wife your husband your spouse
your partner the kids you know those are
priorities for the day they might have
those are just like that's a priority it
has to get done today and this specific
date has to get done you know it can't
get done tomorrow because it wouldn't be
priority if it was tomorrow today it's a
priority right priorities
or today
so what must it's not just a to-do list
because lots of things on to-do lists
like I bet you've written to-do lists
before and isn't it true a to-do list
sometimes for you carries over to
tomorrow
well that's the difference between a
priority and a to-do list
follow
because sometimes you write things on
to-do list it's okay if you add them to
it three days from now 10 days from now
50 days from now a priority today
urgent immediate necessary let's deal
with it today
and not just emergency reaction but you
put it there it was on your Battle Board
it was in your game plan it's in your
high performance planner it's gonna
happen today
got it
so this this idea of done by one has
really served me throughout my life and
I really want you to hear this guys
because I can't be more honest about
something than this one I'm not a
morning person
I am absolutely not a morning person and
I still Implement done by one mentality
even as I'm not a morning person
you know I'm I mean some of you know me
for a long time or if you're new to the
membership I can welcome here I'll tell
you some things about myself once in a
while as we do these I'm kind of a Nutty
Professor in the morning
you know I wake up you know Denise is so
happy and she's excited to do things and
I walk out into the kitchen and she's
like hi she hits a meal with a list of
74 things she's thought of and done
she's already downloaded from the
universe all the obligations in the
history of humanity as a woman as a
leader as a wife as a daughter caregiver
family leader she's she's already got it
all down and I'm kind of like huh
like my brain does not kick on I think
it used to kick on a little bit faster
but since 2011 when I had my brain
injury it's a little slower I'm on a
slow roll in the morning and you know I
don't turn to a cup of coffee usually I
just let my brain kind of wake up and I
start you know moving my body so some of
you know my morning routine
I do 20 minutes of movement so I do yoga
calisthenics stretching or a walk or a
jog or just something for 20 minutes
and it's not it's not my work out of the
day it's just to open up my body get
Mobility activate right then I spend 20
minutes with a book something good
something I can read that is inspiring
makes me think because my brain turned
on by reading
then if I don't feel like reading for
any reason if I don't feel like reading
for the 20 minutes I'll close my eyes
I'll visualize and think through the day
then I'll spend 20 minutes with my high
performance planner and people like you
spend 20 minutes with your high points
planner and I think I've misspoken on
that a few times and you guys busted me
on it it's okay
um in that I spend 20 minutes with the
high performance planner and usually
like a battle board type thing so I'll
fill out the high performance planner
I'll consider the overall context of
what I'm doing so I'll flip more to
those monthly pages in the high
performance planner and then I'll kind
of sit there I'll visualize I'll think
about it okay
I'll walk through the day how could I do
that activity with Excellence today
how could I be really present today what
might trip me up today the question is
the high performance planner I'll take
those on and then as I do all that I'll
go okay
I'm I'm ready for the day now you know
I'm ready for the day and I get excited
because that morning warm up my body's
open my mind is open
my day is planned before that though I'm
gonna you know and then bam so I gotta
go through that hour in the morning but
then I'm ready to go
and then my mentality that doesn't
matter if if that happened if I had a
late night and it's 10 a.m and I do that
by 11 A.M
still my question would be okay gosh I'm
only starting work here at 11 o'clock
shoot Brennan it's 11 o'clock I'm only
starting at 11 o'clock Brendan
done by one what would you absolutely
have to SWAT team by 1 pm to be done by
one
and I cannot tell you how powerful this
mentality is because guess what it is
it's your insurance policy
because if you finished your major
priorities and your major needle moving
activities by one
then all the firefighting and emergency
and reactive things you have to do the
rest of the day you got time for it
you know you want to explore something
you want to get distracted to looking at
something hey more power to you you are
done by one
you wanna deep dive into something you
dork about spend another hour on your
passion spend that extra 30 minutes to
the gym today no problem done by one
you follow how powerful this is it's
your insurance policy get it done by one
rule number three is manage your time
effectively with Jim quick the T in
Limitless stands for time time
management and we're thinking that you
know most people have gone through or
read a book on time management and I
just really do believe it's not just
time management it's all these other
ways of managing our productivity and
time is one of those things but I'm
excited to talk about this today now
there's this quote that says tomorrow is
often the busiest day of the week
tomorrow is often the busiest day of the
week because everyone says I'll do it
tomorrow and tomorrow never comes right
that's a someday and how do you really
do the things you need to do in the time
that you have and so let me start by
asking you a question I just want you to
imagine for a moment take a moment and
imagine you can close your eyes even if
you like or just continue to watch this
imagine there is a bank account that
credits your account every morning with
86
400 it carries over no balance from day
to day
now every evening the bank deletes
whatever part of the balance you fail to
use during the day
what would you do
you draw out every cent of course
you see each of us has a bank
it's called time
every morning it credits you with 86 400
seconds
every night it writes off as a loss
whatever of this you have failed to
invest to a purpose
it carries over no balance
it allows no overdraft
every day it opens a new account for you
every night it burns the remains of the
day
if you fail to use the day's deposits
the loss is yours there is no drawing
against tomorrow
you must live in the present on today's
deposits invest in it as to get from it
the utmost in health happiness and
contribution
so I want you to think about that and in
another way of looking at it imagine you
do have eighty six thousand four hundred
dollars in a bank account for that day
and somebody stole from you ten dollars
what would you do
would you spend the other all the rest
of the money trying to get that ten
dollars back when you spend the eighty
six thousand three hundred and ninety
dollars that you have left to try to get
that ten dollars back of course not you
would let that go but it's so
interesting when it comes to people's
time because whatever you do in your
time those are votes for who you want to
be and what's most important to you but
a lot of times what we'll do is you know
we'll create this storm we'll create
this storm inside that disrupts our
productivity and now some things could
only be learned in a storm but sometimes
we create our own storms and we get
upset when it rains right and sometimes
we'll go after that ten dollars and
we'll use all the resources we have all
this time and energy and emotion and a
lot of times our time our feelings I
mean how many of you have ever had a
time in your life where the day just
flew by right it was a set of these
emotions because when you're having fun
you lose track of time or maybe on the
opposite side you're doing something
that you don't want to be doing and it
just takes a long time and you feel
bored so a lot of the time is actually
feelings and so I want to talk about in
this session is really how I manage my
time now this is just one pillar one of
the nine different things that you can
manage the things that you have control
over the things you have influence over
because remember we all have 24 hours in
a day
right and it's how we invest it how we
use that time that pays us the returns
the Rewards or maybe it even punishes us
also as well so how can you get the most
of today my first recommendation my
first quick tip for you is first assess
how you're using your time when we
talked about this mind experiment where
you have 86 400 in your bank account you
know every single dollar represents a
second so how are you investing your
time right now and so I want you to take
a moment and take a piece of paper take
out your notebook that you have for your
quick productivity and I want you to
just think about your day
how are you investing your time so for
example some people use an app they have
an app on their phone it could tell them
how much time they spend on social media
today or yesterday and you maybe you
might want to look that up how much time
did you spend on email
how much did you spend time on working
out
how much time did you spend on the phone
you know or in meetings
they say that the average person's
working less than three hours a day in
productive work even though they're
putting in maybe eight hours so how are
you utilizing your time so the first
part self-awareness you can't manage
something we're talking about time
management you can't manage something
unless you what unless you measure it so
where is your time presently going the
second thing I would recommend is
something called time blocking time
blocking you know many of this most
successful individuals they don't use
to-do lists instead what they do is they
badge the activities that they need to
accomplish together in blocks of time
now what do I mean by that so for
example for me I have two primary
activities that I focus on each day I'm
creating or I'm communicating that
that's for me for everybody else it's
different everybody's job and
responsibility is something else so for
me what I'll do is I'll I'll dedicate
whole days where I just create content
whole days because what happens is if I
go from content to connecting and back
to content I am switching contexts and
what way does that do it wastes time and
I have to activate a different part of
my brain so I've revved up this part of
my brain it's all warmed up and then all
of a sudden I stop cold and I have to
reactivate a different part of my brain
and then in order to be able to
communicate or to negotiate right or to
be able to present and so my goal here
is I time batch things I batch things
around the things the activities that I
do and you might not have flexibility in
your job or your career to do that so
then you could break it down by parts of
the day so for example
let's say that maybe the first few hours
of the day you are focusing on what
making things the first few hours a day
you're just making you're you are
creating the next few hours what are you
doing maybe you're managing you're in
management mode and you're managing your
work or you're managing uh
Communications also as well and then
maybe the last three hours of the day of
your work day if you will you're in
marketing mode and that's where you're
doing all your outbound your social
media your emails that you're writing
and you're in marketing mode the goal
here is never to get perfect because you
won't get it perfect but if you start
batching the activities that you need
around certain periods of time instead
of just having a to-do list you don't
have to switch from activity to activity
and it burns a lot of energy and it
wastes a lot of time so when I'm talking
about blocking time leaders what they do
is they'll batch and block times around
the activities that they have so maybe
they'll do all their calls at a certain
in the afternoon or maybe Tuesday
afternoons is when they do phone calls
and this is the other thing you can
batch by activity we talked about that
you can batch by time you could also
batch by environment sometimes if you
work in a certain environment some
people have different work environments
and they'll do one activity in one
environment and they'll do their calls
while they go for a walk or they'll do
their calls when they're on their
elliptical so you can batch by time you
could batch by activity you could batch
by location you could also batch by your
energy meaning there's certain times of
the day we talked about this when you
have more energy than others and this is
your Creative Energy so if you have a
Creative Energy very vibrant you're a
morning individual and you are an early
bird maybe that's your time that you
decide to allocate writing right because
you're batching around energy you could
also batch around people maybe you're
working with a team at work or you're
working with your kids or you're working
with other individuals and you can batch
around activities around that being
around those certain people right so you
could do it around time you could run a
location you could around people you
could match around energy and activity
also as well and building on people
there's some studies that suggest that
certain activities are well done by
collaboration and so learning and
productivity it can be social but also
learning and productivity could also be
solo and so it's different for each
individual some people like
collaboration or they like working
remotely and they like working on Zoom
because it gives them energy other
people are more introverted and they
like to rejuvenate and be creative by
themselves and there's no right or wrong
here the whole point of this program is
to give you enough idea is to figure out
what inspires me what instructions what
insights what can I do here and get
feedback so some people love being
around people they love to batch around
people they love to collaborate with
individuals
test it for you you might be more of a
solo individual you like to be more
creative and get more done really
focused on yourself so people makes a
difference another way of optimizing
your time besides time blocking and
batching is to use that transmission
time meaning when you are in transit and
you're going from one context to another
use that time to learn use that time to
work often when we are you're on your
career and train or you're on an
airplane or you're commuting to work
that's a wonderful time to be able to
fill in to be able to get your five hour
rule the five hour rule from Benjamin
Franklin says you want to be able to
learn an hour a day and maybe that hour
comes from your commute to work maybe
you want to turn your car or your
automobile into a university on Wheels
and that's how you're going to be more
time efficient you're going to listen to
your podcast or you're going to maybe to
listen to your podcast at 1.5 or 2x
faster and that allows you to use your
commute time to be able to get more done
in less time the truth is we have enough
time
86 400 seconds but the challenge is
we're not paying attention to that time
and where it's going presently so what
are the choices you can make Upstream to
really direct your time you know I
believe that we are the pilot of Our
Lives we're not the passenger so how can
you take your responsibility your
ability to your sovereignty if you will
to be able to influence with the simple
choices you make every single day also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is practice
batching with Tim Ferriss one of the
concepts one of the strategies that I
most commonly asked about from the four
hour work week is batching there are
many many many finer points to this and
quite aside from of course 80 20
delegating Outsourcing Parkinson's law
batching comes up again and again and
and so what is batching to explain it in
simplest terms we can talk about laundry
all right so you wouldn't do your
laundry every time you have a new pair
of dirty socks you wait for a certain
critical mass of dirty laundry to
accumulate and then you do the laundry
why
same with post office if you have many
different types of mail that are going
to come together that you need to mail
you're going to wait for a certain
critical mass as opposed to just going
there for every single letter because
there's a setup cost there is a task
switching cost getting in the car
driving there spending the gas spending
the time laundry putting it all together
detergent and so on right so the the
time and labor involved in doing one
letter or 20 or one pair of socks or an
entire basket of clothing is the same
and you want to be both effective and
efficient with your allocation of
resources I.E time if you apply those to
business you can apply them in a million
and one different ways
and I'll give you a few examples one of
the most common
I suppose directional questions or
specifics that I'm asked about is
frequency well do I batch on a daily
basis do I batch on a weekly basis do I
batch on a monthly or quarterly basis
and the answer is I do all of those
things but you don't have to try it all
at once and I would not encourage you do
that I would encourage you to perhaps
try one or two approaches and see what
works for you this is a very personal
set of techniques you develop a
portfolio that works for yourself let me
tell you a few things that I and others
do for instance
you might decide that on a given day
from the time you wake up until lunch is
your primary creation period this could
be writing it could be recording it
could be anything that is proactively
creative and synthesis then once you
have lunch you are permitted to do
administrative tasks phone calls email
triage calendaring and so on I do this
quite a lot particularly from Tuesday to
Thursday uh on certain weeks on a weekly
basis I know the CEO of a very
well-known startup pretty much everyone
watching this would know this company
and instead of batching on a daily basis
looking at his week Monday to Friday he
might have day one administrative tasks
day two HR hiring day three product day
four marketing and on each of those days
you will focus on thematically or
categorically those types of tasks that
is yet another approach and very
commonly I will batch phone calls
on Mondays and Fridays and in I was even
broadly speaking this is voice related
tasks so I will have phone calls and
podcast recording on Mondays and Fridays
and this helps to prevent also
interruptions and task switching that
can result if you have miscellaneous
phone calls and podcasts scattered
throughout the week makes it very
difficult to do deep work on anything
that might require three to five hours
of uninterrupted time on a on a
quarterly basis you could look at batch
producing or completing certain types of
normally scattered activities for
instance I am recording this video right
now during a Content generation week
where a week is blocked out once per
quarter to focus on answering common
questions that all of you or my readers
or listeners have asked and so on and so
forth on a say six month to yearly basis
I I have started in the last few years
batching travel why would I batch travel
you know there are many different
reasons to best travel one of my reasons
is that I want to practice being off the
grid for extended periods of time
to not only remind myself and prove to
myself that it is possible to do that
and no the internet will not stop the
universe will not end if you are
unavailable and unreachable for certain
periods of time
and also to rejuvenate to recharge being
away from social media and keyboards and
laptop screens and so on batching is one
of the fundamental concepts that you
need to understand if you understand the
principle the reasons for it the
concepts you can come up with your own
examples to experiment with and these
are not permanent changes think of them
as two-week experiments one tiny thing
that you can test assuming that it's on
a daily or weekly basis and try it out
see what works keep what works reject
what doesn't add what is uniquely you're
on borrowing from Bruce Lee with that
and before you know it you will have a
reliable dependable way of making
yourself more effective and more
efficient which is your bespoke
iteration of batching rule number 5 is
love what you do with Tom Bilu next
question Stephen Davis in the beginning
did you work as much as you do now or
have you improved over time how have you
increased productivity and discipline to
work 18 hours a day all right so it
depends on when you're starting that
clock because when I was
um just out of college I was insanely
lazy and I'm so embarrassed and I never
I actually don't want myself to lose
sight of how lazy I was nor do I want
people who follow me to lose sight of
how lazy I was because I want people to
understand you can become anything you
want to become
you create who you are you don't
discover it
talked about that earlier
so that is really really important but I
used to be insanely lazy now as I began
to change my identity and strive to
become the person that I wanted to
become instead of focusing on who I was
then I realized that being lazy and
giving into that was not going to take
me where I wanted to go it didn't make
me feel more alive and so as I fed into
the things that made me feel alive as I
found those Flames as I changed my
identity made demands of myself altered
my belief system and really began to
invest emotionally by rewarding myself
for my ability to go hard to work to
push forward on things that I really
believe in to invest in things that make
me feel alive to make the demand that
the thing that I'm working my ass off
for is something that I really believe
in and that's why man do not follow me
nor listen to my advice if you don't
love what you do because if you don't
love what you do and you work 18 hours a
day you are a fool and you will hate
your life and you will look back with
nothing but regret
so the last thing I want is somebody to
take my advice on the surface and miss
the part where I say find something you
would die for and live for it make the
demand that the way you make your living
the way you earn your money is doing
something that you care deeply about
that gives you more energy than it takes
now if you have all of that in place you
cannot accept weakness from yourself you
need to be pushing forward you need to
make huge demands of yourself because
that is how you will optimize your
abilities that is how you will actually
uh um actuate your potential and do the
things you want to do and gaining skills
and getting better at something is
what's going to allow you to actually
have the kind of impact that you want to
have now when you have that core when
you understand that the harder you work
the more reverberations you can have in
the world remember my very definition of
power
is you close your eyes
you imagine a world
a world that is better than the one that
you currently live in one that you want
to be real
and then you open your eyes and you have
the ability to make that world come true
that's power
that is power
if you want to cultivate that power in
your life it comes down to busting your
ass to gain skills that matter to you
and live in service not only of yourself
but of other people
so that's how I increased my
productivity and discipline because I
care about what I'm doing it makes me
feel alive it makes me feel energized it
is exciting I wake up excited to see if
I can pull this off I wake up excited to
work hard to get better because I know
that it actually has real world
implications
so I didn't start this way I don't think
anybody does you have to cultivate it
you create this stuff and it all starts
with cultivating
that passion rule number six is increase
your awareness with Brian Tracy most
people procrastinate at some point in
their lives and it's usually over things
that they don't enjoy doing uh or they
feel overwhelmed about or they put it
off because they're not as fun or as
satisfying as doing other things there's
always a reason to procrastinate
now that's one of the reasons I'm such a
big fan of diving into a cold pool first
thing in the morning because if you can
get that out of your way first it's
pretty easy to deal with anything else
that comes your way so what I do I now
have a home with a big pool but I do as
I get up in the morning and I quickly go
downstairs and jump in the pool before I
have time to think about it and Wham you
jump in that pool you hit that water and
you're on your way for the rest of the
day for some people procrastinating
seems to take the pressure off of us for
a moment but the longer we procrastinate
the more the stress builds as the time
between when we intended to accomplish a
task and when we actually accomplish it
your ability to overcome the tendency to
procrastinate is going to be the key to
your success the great one Wayne Gretzky
was fond of saying you miss a hundred
percent of the shots you don't take
and procrastination is a guaranteed way
of assuring that you're not taking
enough shots
think of it this way once a difficult
task is finally done we feel a great
sense of relief of uh exhilaration
you might wonder why you put it off for
so long too and you vow never to get in
the same position again
it's possible to stop that cycle with
some actionable steps and changes in how
you look at the tasks in front of you
I wrote a book on procrastination a few
years ago that has now sold two million
500 000 copies in 51 languages all over
the world
and people say it changes their life and
you'll say it as well
overcoming procrastination involves
actively checking in on your own
personal growth so that you can ensure
that you're making progress towards your
goals and not getting off track
first recognize when you are
procrastinating you're probably often
aware that you are procrastinating but
it's not always obvious in the beginning
stages
if you're doing any of the following
things you're sure as heck probably
procrastinating
does this sound like you
a task keeps showing up on your to-do
list day after day or even week after
week even though you know it's important
but you're not getting it done
or you opt to start your day with low
priority tasks instead of ones that have
a looming deadline or take longer to
finish
or you're easily distracted by the need
to get up for a snack check your email
look at social media or any other easy
or even mindless tasks once you do
decide to sit down and work on an
important task we call this the
attraction of distraction
you agree to take on low priority tasks
that people ask you to do throughout the
day instead of sticking with your high
priority to-do list
or you keep waiting to and get in the
right mood or find the perfect time to
tackle a task you kind of talk to
yourself and think of reasons to put it
off
in aware of Habits Like These can help
you prevent procrastination by
proactively avoiding them
as you become aware of procrastinating
and understand why you are doing it you
can overcome it and then turn it into
execution angle number seven the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is live with a sense of purpose with Mel
Robbins you're thinking way too big
way too big
when you think of passion and purpose
you're like I gotta find my
pouch I gotta figure out my legacy I got
a little life of purpose I gotta figure
the thing out it's like Gotta Be My
Career no that's not it at all everybody
let me tell you a story
so I have a daughter I think I've talked
about her before she's a junior at the
University of Southern California
she is a singer-songwriter and she got
into this crazy program at the Thornton
School of Music at USC to study get this
being a pop music singer-songwriter
there's 24 kids in the program there
were only two singer songwriters
accepted she was one of them this kid
basically earned her way in to like
winning American Idol she's working with
all these Grammy a winning word excuse
me winning artist blah blah blah
she is so focused
on this big fear and this big dream
the big dream
is having a career as a
singer-songwriter
she literally said to me
a couple months ago mom
I actually see it
I can see myself in a stadium
I can see people singing along
I can see that this happens
and then she says but I'm paralyzed
because
uh what if it doesn't happen
what if I'm not good enough
what if I try and I don't make it
she is so focused on the big dream and
the big fear everybody
that she's not living with a sense of
purpose
every single day
and she's not bringing the energy
by doing things that she's passionate
about into every single day
I want you to stop right now let's just
make an agreement everybody you're going
to stop right now
thinking about purpose as your career
you are going to stop thinking
that passion and purpose is your legacy
the thing that will change your mind
is if you were to wake up every day
and ask yourself a simple question
what can I do
to feel a little more energized today
and what would it mean
to live
with a little more purpose today
I want you to think about purpose and
passion
as something you practice on a daily
basis
that gives you room to have a change on
a daily basis
because if we take my daughter Kendall's
uh situation for example if she were to
wake up every morning and we've been
having these discussions if she were to
wake up every morning
and ask yourself how can I feel a little
more energized today
I guarantee you she would either say I
could get outside and go for a run
she could say I'm going to spend 20
minutes
working on a chord projection I can't
even say the word progression for a song
I'm writing
I could reach out to this place I want
to intern this summer
I could reach out to a friend and make a
lunch date she's bringing energy into
her life by us at thinking about it
and then doing it and if she asks
herself how could I live with a little
bit greater sense of purpose today
by simply shrinking it to your
day-to-day it makes it accessible and it
makes you something that you practice
which makes you more connected to it and
you know I got to tell you what's so
cute is that you know I when I um wake
up in the morning
I always text all three of our kids
because we're in this kind of Zone in
life where uh you know Kendall's in Los
Angeles Sawyer's in downtown Boston our
son is going to high school in Vermont
I'm often in between Vermont and Boston
or I'm traveling for work
and I always text them every morning uh
when I wake up and this morning I texted
Kendall
and uh it was six o'clock in the morning
and I said good morning I hope you had
an awesome night last night because you
deserve it I can't wait to see you this
Sunday
she texted back immediately everybody
at three o'clock in the morning L.A time
mom you're gonna die
and I'm like uh oh was she arrested what
the hell happened and she goes I'm
writing a song with Michael Michael's
this kidner program who is like a super
uber genius I'm like oh my God I can't
wait it's 3 A.M you know go to bed she's
like I can't I'm so excited I'm doing
that purpose thing he and then she sends
me a photo from three o'clock in the
morning where she's sitting behind
Michael as he's the producer mixing up
the Bass track on this thing that they
just wrote
and she's like Mom this works I've been
thinking about just how can I be more
purposeful every day and this morning I
said I'm gonna ask Michael if he'll help
me finish this song I texted him and now
we're working on it
see
absolutely love it if she were to sit in
that intellectual Wasteland going
what's my purpose am I gonna get to the
arena how do I live with Barbara no
everybody
final mistake and this is the most
important one
stop thinking so big
let's think really small because
remember it's the little things that are
everything
and this little question I want you to
ask yourself every single morning
how can I what can I do to feel more
energized today
and how can I live with a greater sense
of purpose today
that will change
your ability to bring more purpose into
your life to stay connected to it and to
bring more energy and passion into your
day-to-day life
do you know something in the game of
life you're playing a cricket match
against an entity called the mind
no one on planet Earth can stop you from
accomplishing and achieving what you
want if you can
bat
against the Googlies
that the Mind bowls at you
how many of you have experienced that
the mild bowls Google is
[Music]
good
when it comes to exercising and jogging
how many of you know that the Mind bowls
Googles matcha
soja
how many of you have trouble in studying
raise your hands as students
[Music]
started by WhatsApp don't get distracted
by internet pornography don't get
distracted by Twitter don't get
distracted by Facebook study don't get
distracted by birds to do bird watching
study all these distractions
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll tell you something my God why
because the mind doesn't want you to win
the game of life
how many of you wanted to wake up early
in the morning resonance only wanted I
asked
wanted to wake up early in the morning
and how many of you have done something
called as
setting an alarm clock
and then after setting the alarm clock
that's an alarm
whether you want it or not it rings
and when it rings the Mind puts its
first googly
what does the Mind do by putting the
googly makes you clean bold when you do
the first snooze
you are out
you are out
if you snooze you are out
I want to say one thing just one and
probably this will change the direction
of your life you know something when you
snooze the alarm
what happens
you decide to give into the mind's ball
and this is how your morning Begins by
giving into the mind
foreign
[Music]
you tell yourself that what I decided
last night is not as important what is
important is what the mind says because
we listen
I'll tell you something my humble advice
because it's not just about getting up
in the morning it's about every aspect
of life whether it's your work if you're
working whether it's your study if
you're studying whatever we do
the problem is
it's not about one thing it reflects in
every area of life
is
[Music]
don't allow that snooze I think one of
my first things in failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an automated
response saying your application will
not go any further
I can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a interaction with me they
just saw my name they saw I'd been a
monk for three years that resume is
useless I mean what's your transferable
skills like sitting in silence yeah
surprise surprise no one wants to hire a
monk and so they rejected you but that's
not personal because they didn't meet me
in person but what if they had me right
so that's the first the first step is
don't take all fear failure I'll give an
example me and you we reach out to
countless guests to be on our podcast we
say no all the time we're saying all the
time but if I don't hear a no from the
guest directly that's not a no like
someone's team can say no someone's
assistant can say no someone's PR team
can say no but until they say no
personally it's not a no okay but when
they do say no then that's enough yeah
so then let's move how do you deal with
that type of failure yes so if I deal
with a failure where someone meets me in
person and gets to know Jay you're
horrible you suck like I don't want to
deal with a monk ever in my life yeah I
would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah that how do
you deal with that type of so I've had
you say this I've said it a couple of
times and I'm sure it's been repeated a
bunch of times around how I genuinely
believe failure has feedback feedback
and and so for me it's like failure has
the ability to actually tell you what
you need to improve now not to improve
to get their attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games you know on
the big stages you didn't have the
skills you didn't have the teamwork you
guys weren't hungry enough you were
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah I think a lot of people can do that
in life but we're so afraid to like go
on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh I'm just
gonna give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
I think that's great mental training too
I think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so there's
that season that Michael Jordan everyone
is agreement in an agreement that he is
one of the best players to be playing
and they keep losing they need to make
the fight they didn't make the finals
they lost and then they realized they
need to get the team and they need to
find their I think they're bringing
Dennis Rodman and then they start
bringing in all these other players that
strengthen whereas if they would have
just said oh we got the best player in
the world we just keep doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am a failure
at the end of your day or week do you
ever find yourself worried or frustrated
because no matter how much effort you
put in to work and no matter how hard
you work your financial situation and
your financial future may never seem to
be improving you might be finding
yourself living paycheck to paycheck
right now with not a lot of breathing
room and I would imagine no discretion
missionary income or even time to spend
on the little things that really would
make your life more enjoyable well what
I can share with you is you're not alone
that's number one and in most cases the
real problem is not your current
circumstances what the real problem is
that most people repeat the same
patterns of thought and behaviors over
and over again and that is the cause of
what more of the same results but they
are looking for different results and so
today I'm going to show you how to break
that pattern break that cycle now you
see when you think of your results your
results are effects and so the question
is effects of what and the answer is
your results are all effects of what you
believe to be true about yourself what
you believe to be true that is possible
and it also comes down to what are your
daily habits now if you think about what
you believe and if you think about your
habits that is what is causing the
effect that you may not like right now
and so a a simple logical thing to do
would be to understand that if I could
change my beliefs about what was
possible and what was possible for me
specifically and I could create more
empowering habits than my result will
change and what I love to focus on
having done an enormous amount of brain
research over the last 10 years is
something called your inner game and
your inner game is comprised of
obviously your beliefs your attitude
your perceptions how you see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action and so
let me share just a little story with
you that may help you understand what I
mean
about two years ago I was at a seminar
and when I got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and I could
see she was somewhere in her you know
50s maybe early 60s she looked nice she
was a vibrant woman she was walking
right towards me and I saw tears
streaming down her eyes and when she got
through the crowd
for a moment I thought that maybe there
was something wrong but she actually had
tears of joy in her eyes and when I met
her her name was Joni Sanderson and this
was in Perth Australia and she came up
to me she said thank you so much and I
go well for what she says well
about a year ago I heard you speak about
beliefs and habits and mastering my
emotions and really working on my
self-worth and she said to me that she
was a caregiver and that she loved
helping families who needed extra
assistance for their aging parents or
for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a Widow's pension of about twelve
thousand Aussie dollars a year and so
she really didn't have enough money to
be able to take the care of her
grandkids that she wanted to to be able
to take her children on a vacation and
so I shared with her why do you think
that you're only earning twelve thousand
dollars a year and she said I don't know
and when I shared with her that she
possibly believed that that's what she
was worth and she said to me I think I'm
worth more I said well you might be able
to declare that you're worth more but if
at a deeper level of your brain you have
this feeling that maybe you're not smart
enough or not good enough or not worthy
enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior and so what I helped Joni do
prior to her coming to me and being in
gratitude was I helped her recognize
that beliefs Drive Behavior beliefs
Drive emotions habits Drive behavior and
in order to change your results living
paycheck to paycheck being stressed out
worrying about your future even your
presence circumstances right now why not
focus on working on the neural patterns
the beliefs and habits that are nothing
more than patterns in the brain that
drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and so
she started to work on what I call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel more confident more
certain and more empowered and what I
can share with you is she at that moment
told me that she went from making twelve
thousand dollars a year as a widows from
a Widow's pension and living paycheck to
paycheck to being able to charge for her
Services as she was making 75
000 a year if you think that your
thoughts have something to do with your
future just from a theoretical
standpoint that your thoughts Create
Your Destiny and you think sixty to
seventy thousand thoughts in one day and
ninety percent of those thoughts are the
same thoughts as the day before well
then your life isn't going to change
very much as long as you're thinking the
same way and those those same thoughts
lead to the same choices the same
choices lead to the same behaviors the
same behaviors create the exact same
experiences and we anticipate the same
feelings or emotions from those
experiences and those emotions are the
payoff that drive our very same thoughts
while our biology our neuroscircuitry a
neurochemistry our hormones and even our
gene expression will be equal to how we
think how we act and how we feel and how
we think how we act and how we feel as
is called our personality and our
personality creates our personal reality
that's it so the present personality
who's listening to this show has created
the present personal reality called
their life so if you can latch on to
this idea if you want to create a new
life a new personal reality you got to
change your personality which means you
better start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and changing it you
begin to become conscious of your
unconscious actions or habits or
behaviors and modify them
and then we have to begin to look at the
emotions that we live by every single
day
that'll keep us connected to the past
and decide do these emotions belong in
our future so most people are trying to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right and
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then that kind of box in the brain
that is the habit of ourselves it's a
we're 95 percent of the time right
running a series of programs so then
sitting and doing the work had we have
to become disentangled from those
programs and so the moment you decide to
do something differently or make a new
choice but most people don't want to
face is that discomfort and that that
discomfort that that uncertainty that
lack of predictability the that that
that unknown is what people are afraid
of because they'd rather live in guilt
at least they can predict who they're
going to be then take a chance and
possibility so when a person begins to
understand this and you say well
how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and
you say why 35 years because 35 years
ago I had this one event well the
stronger the emotion you feel from
reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion because it's the emotion that
keeps you anchored to the past so that
sounds really good theoretically but
when you step out into that unknown into
that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and it's producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy than be in this this
conference so then at least then when
they return back to that familiar
feeling then they feel safe so they step
out in the unknown and the body starts
influencing the mind saying you can
start tomorrow you're too busy it's your
mother's fault you know it's your
culture's fault I don't have enough
money this isn't going to work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then
to meditate it means to become familiar
with so as you become familiar with
those thoughts you become conscious of
how you speak you become aware of how
you act you notice how you're feeling
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious programs the less
unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why because it's not enough to just have
a great meditation and get up and get on
the freeway and get in traffic and
getting stressed you just return back to
the old self again our job then
is to sustain that modified State of
Mind and Body the entire day and if you
can
get ready because something different or
unusual is going to begin to happen in
your life and it will come as a
coincidence or synchronicity and that's
breadcrumbs from the Divine saying
you're on the path just keep doing it
there'll be another one just keep
staying in that energy and so teaching
people then to understand that there's a
formula that we now know that if you
apply that formula you'll begin to see
those changes and now as people are
doing it more and more
effectively the results are going up as
well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which
uh the community can change brain or
heart coherence they they know how to do
it it's not uh something that's that's
separate from them they've practiced it
enough times that they they now know how
to do it so what's the significance of
that well really simple in your life
if you start returning back to the same
reactions to the same people and
circumstances you're returning back to
the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological a
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work he can't tell me you had
a turbulent past or or that you're too
overweight or too underweight or too out
of shape or you can't even tell me that
you've never meditated before in fact
some of our greatest
scans or people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 and not sixty percent
and when we do a week-long event we got
a thousand people or 1500 people and
they are all in and that when they start
getting Beyond themselves that first day
or second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting most
people focus on the problem instead of
the solution and that is why they failed
I like to say that there are a million
reasons why your ideas will never work
out and only eight why they will either
way you're right so it's better to focus
on the eight Your Heroes the people that
you look up to the people that you love
and want to be like right Your Heroes
all succeeded with less than what you
currently have right now if they can all
do it so can you the only thing in your
way are your excuses so one of the
things that I love most about both my
wife and my team is that they're always
willing to find the way one of the
things that Nina loves most about
herself I had her fill out this form
maybe two years ago of like what do you
love most about yourself and at the top
was she's a fast learner she loves
learning new things she loves taking on
new challenges and I love that I love
that about her and I love that in people
I think you should be a fast learner I
think you should love learning I think
you should always be taking on New
Opportunities right now my YouTube
channel I've split up my channel into
eight or nine different channels and
then just recently I split them up again
where we launched a top 10 Channel just
for the top 10 videos so the top 10
videos aren't on my main Channel anymore
and uh then we're doing an everything
Channel where if you just want all the
content it's all on one spot so it's
chaos it's crazy my whole team has to be
restructured and everybody's taking on
new projects and responsibilities and we
were supposed to have a one month
transition phase to do it
that was the recommendation that was
that was the aggressive recommendation
does it have a one month transition
period and for me one month just as
death it is death I mean I said okay
great one month but then as I'm into it
on the Tuesday of like the first week
like guys we need to launch like this
weekend
[Laughter]
problems and yes we're gonna make so
many mistakes and people aren't trained
properly and there's more work and we
need to you know we figure out who wants
to do what and how so many issues
awesome let's go
I think about Rey for example on my team
who has been doing all these thumbnails
so I have a I have a set design for my
top 10 rules thumbnails that people love
and it's it's been going like that for
years and I've always been on my team to
say I don't care that everybody thinks
their thumbnails are great they can be
better how do we make them better and so
finally finally after years of testing
we finally found the format that would
win that would that would beat our
original thumbnails and there's minor
differences we zoom in on the face we
got rid of the second logo make the text
bigger minor differences and then Rey
has been going back and updating split
tests doing against our old videos we
have 13 1400 different split tests on my
videos it's crazy I think I split test
more than anybody on YouTube so he's
going back and updating all the old
thumbnails
and trying to prove a winner each time
and he's maybe I don't know halfway
through these are think about how many
videos we have on the channel we've got
6 000 videos a lot of them are our top
10.
now with this change I found a new
format
we found a new format a new thumbnail
different color scheme different text
different pictures
different logo new thumbnail format and
we found that it's working and so I said
Ray
I know you just changed all the
thumbnails
we gotta do it again it's like this is
so exciting let's go I love this guy so
much right where most people what are
they they're gonna complain they're
gonna say I just did all this work or
this other thing right
you don't want to be around people like
that and you definitely don't want to be
that for too many people the problem is
for so many people that's you that's not
even people around you that's you you're
thinking about all the sunk costs that
you put into something you're thinking
about invested so much into this thing
and and now you want me to shift
everything
yep
you need to be on the yep side now you
need to adopt that kind of mindset that
kind of personality that just because I
work before it doesn't mean it's going
to keep working you find something new
it's better let's go this is what the
whole game is about so how do you do it
how do you be more resourceful I'm going
to give you a three-step process that I
think will help step number one is focus
on the eight so I said at the beginning
there are a million reasons why it's not
going to work out and if you talk to
your friends and family and and social
media they'll find a million more
reasons why it's not going to work out
great there's a million reasons why it's
not going to work out
now there's two million and there's
eight while it will
only focused on the eighth focus on the
eighth be be rigid be disciplined stop
thinking about those negative things are
still there awesome those reasons sure
are awesome great I'm only focused on
the eight
I don't care but all the reasons why
it's not gonna work out
that that's that's where most of the
world lives that's the land of
negativity I'm here and it's a small
Lane it's easier there's only eight
reasons why I'm gonna win I'm just gonna
pick those eight and focus on that
that's it choose it's a choice
you're right either way right you are
right if you say I'm not gonna win
because I don't have the education and
the resources and the money and the
parents and you're right
you've already decided you're right yes
absolutely you're right but
people with less resources less
connections less ideas less Talent less
skills than you they've done it
you're just full of excuses if you want
to believe the excuses then you have
already lost if you want to buy into the
eight reasons why you're going to win
and surround yourself with your Heroes
who have done it and that's a daily
source of inspiration for you to keep
going off and doing it then you will win
focus on the eight not the Million
number two is model success
this is what really helped me I mean now
I have I have all these channels and
we're modeling success all day long and
I've built an entire business around
this but this is the thing that saved my
business from the from the first start
right like Bill Gates how he built
Microsoft saved my company
right learning from his story made me
finally start to have some success in my
business and then from there every
morning I would I would read a little
bit about a successful entrepreneur
now I'd much rather watch a video than
read
um but hack your own learning style
maybe you prefer to listen to podcasts I
listen to zero podcast because I'm not
an auditorial learner learning how to
model success finding people who've done
the thing that you want to do does two
things one it gives you hope seeing what
they came from like go look at Oprah's
story see what she came from
and then for you to say that you have
less resources less available to you
than Oprah did at the time that she was
growing up is ludicrous is crazy you're
way more equipped just because you have
the internet than Oprah ever did when
she was getting started
but maybe you hate Oprah awesome great
who do you want to learn from Jeff Bezos
awesome go look at his store look at the
people who you look up to your Heroes
study them not how they make an extra
million dollars now but zero to one how
did they get started what did they have
to go through learn from them
study them and it gives you inspiration
to know that it's possible and it gives
you strategies because chances are what
work for them could also work for you it
won't work for you 100 it's like trying
on this cowboy hat that's just a little
bit too oversized and you gotta you
gotta tweak it and take in some of the
sides maybe add a little bit more
stitching somewhere so that it fits but
modeling success takes you eighty
percent of the way you don't have to
come up with all the genius ideas
yourself the model's been proven go out
copy it apply it to yourself and start
winning and step number three is tell
yourself this is just a warm-up I love
this strategy I think this is one of the
greatest things you can ever do for your
self-confidence self-love self-respect
is whenever it's difficult whenever it's
hard whenever you you're at your
Breaking Point whenever you're like I
don't know if I can keep going
tell yourself this is just the warm-up
this is just a warm-up I'm capable of
way more than this
and what it does is it actually tricks
your brain a little bit to believe in it
and now you've just broken through a
comfort zone now you've broken through
it to another level of Excellence you've
just raised your standards a little bit
higher it's extremely powerful so let's
think about it if that thing that is all
consuming all encompassing is all you're
capable of doing right now
that's the problem that means you're
never going to grow Beyond this thing
right you're you're never going to scale
and become something bigger because this
is the max that you're capable of doing
and I remember talking to Alex who helps
me run trying to dance salsa and what he
was stressing out about and we have big
Ambitions for this business we have we
have big Ambitions for where Toronto Dan
salsa needs to be and Alex needs to be
the guy to lead it
if this little thing that that feels
all-encompassing right but if this
little thing owns you you're never gonna
get here
so tell yourself this is just a warm-up
I'm capable of way more than this way
more than this is the beginning this is
baby steps I'm way stronger than this
tell yourself that you say it out loud
tell yourself it's just a warm-up like
that put your hand down it's just a
warm-up
say that three times and see how you
feel and then get to work because you
know what it is just a warm up and
you're capable of way more let's go you
don't have to necessarily have done
anything wrong for things to get
completely out of control
it's a terrifying Doctrine but it's not
a hopeless Doctrine because it still
says that there's a way forward there's
a pathway forward and the pathway
forward is to adopt a mode of being that
has some nobility so that you can
tolerate yourself and perhaps even have
some respect for yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned is by well certainly by the
avoidance of Deceit particularly in
language but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually Rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is
there well two as far as I'm concerned
and some of this is from Clinical
experience you know if you take people
and I've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over decades long periods what they
could be like if they were who they were
if they said if they spoke their being
forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world in a number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something I mean you can think
about this yourselves I often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying watching things on YouTube that
not only do you not want to watch that
you don't even care about that make you
feel horrible about watching after
you're done that's probably four hours
right there you know you think well
that's 20 25 hours a week it's 100 hours
a month that's two and a half full work
weeks it's half a year of work weeks per
year and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting
fifty thousand dollars a year is a way
bigger catastrophe than it would be for
me to waste it because I'm not going to
last nearly as long and so if your life
isn't everything it could be you could
ask yourself well what would happen if
you just stopped wasting the
opportunities that are in front of you
you be who knows how much more efficient
10 times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the Pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment both of which are are are our
major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt it isn't merely that your
fate depends on whether or not you get
your act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well
there's nine billion seven billion
people in the world we're going to Peak
at about 9 billion by the way and then
it'll decline rapidly but seven billion
people in the world and who are you
you're just one little dust moat among
that seven billion and so it really
doesn't matter what you do or don't do
but that's simply not the case it's the
wrong model because you're at the center
of a network you're a node in a network
of course that's even more true now that
we have social media you'll you'll know
a thousand people at least over the
course of your life and they'll know a
thousand people each and that puts you
one person away from a million and two
persons away from a billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do they're like dropping
a stone in a pond the ripples move
outward and they affect things in ways
that you can't fully comprehend and it
means that the things that you do and
that you don't do are far more important
than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but I mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice I can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
now when you say well nihilists suffered
dreadfully because there's no meaning in
their life and they still suffer yeah
but the advantage is they have no
responsibility
so that's the payoff and I actually
think that's the motivation say well I
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is a meaningless suffering
but you can always whine about that and
people will feel sorry for you and you
have the option of taking the pathway of
the Martyr so that's a pretty good deal
All Things Considered especially when
the when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well with
sojournitzen figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends because that's
what happened in the 20th century
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn the one unexpected Habit
to increase your productivity check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there modern
entrepreneurship can be for everyone all
of us are immersed in a culture that has
taught us that non-stop work is the most
valuable thing the brain needs breaks